TOP INVESTIGATOR ANDREW
WEISSMANN, HIS PIT BULL, THAT
AND MORE IN OUR BREAKING NEWS
OPENING MONOLOGUE.
BRAND-NEW INFORMATION IN THIS
HOUR FROM SARA CARTER, REPORTING
THAT THE HOUSE INTEL CHAIR DEVIN
NUNES IS NOW ASKING FORMER TOP
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION OFFICIALS
ABOUT HOW MUCH THE FORMER
PRESIDENT KNEW ABOUT THE BOUGHT
AND PAID FOR DOSSIER WHEN HE
FOUND OUT ABOUT IT.
THIS IS THE DOSSIER THAT WAS
FILLED WITH LIES.
TRYING TO INFLUENCE AND
MANIPULATE THE MINDS OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THIS IS THE ONE THAT THE FBI
RELIED HEAVILY ON TO GET THE
FISA WARRANT TO SPY ON THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN ASSOCIATE CARTER PAGE
DURING AN ELECTION YEAR.
SARA CARTER IS REPORTING THAT
CONGRESSMAN NUNES SANTA LETTERS
TOO MANY UNNAMED SENIOR OBAMA
OFFICIALS INTO IN THE ATTEMPT TO
FIND THEIR KNOWLEDGE ABOUT THE
PHONY DOSSIER.
WE HAVE BEEN SAYING ON THE
PROGRAM FOR MONTHS NOW THAT WE
WANT TO KNOW WHAT FORMER OBAMA
OFFICIALS LIKE JOHN BRENNAN,
JAMES CLAPPER, SUSAN RICE, THE
NEW QUEEN OF UNMASKING, SAMANTHA
POWER, AND PRESIDENT OBAMA, WHAT
THEY KNEW WHEN THEY KNEW IT, AND
SARA CARTER HAS ALSO OBTAINED A
LIST OF QUESTIONS AT THE
CHAIRMAN, CHAIRMAN NUNES WANTS
ANSWERS TO.
HERE ARE THE MOST PERTINENT
ONES.
WHEN AND HOW DID YOU FIRST
BECOME AWARE OF ANY INFORMATION
CONTAINED IN THE DOSSIER?
THEY HAVE UNCOVERED THAT THE
OBAMA FBI, DOJ AND
STATE DEPARTMENT OF OBAMA EITHER
WERE GIVEN THE DOSSIER OR WERE
TOLD ABOUT WHAT WAS IN THE
DOSSIER.
SO THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
POTENTIALLY INVOLVED IS DATA AND
WIDESPREAD.
NOW THE NEXT QUESTION, WHO DID
YOU SHARE THIS INFORMATION WITH,
WHEN, AND IN WHAT FORM?
DESCRIBE EVERY INSTANCE.
BEFORE PRESIDENT OBAMA LEFT
OFFICE, HE AMENDED THAT
EXECUTIVE ORDER, ONE, TWO,
TRIPLE THREE, THAT MADE IT
EASIER TO SHARE INFORMATION
ACROSS 17 INTELLIGENCE AGENCY IS
COMING HE NEVER WORKED UNDER
THIS EXECUTIVE ORDER.
THE NEXT QUESTION, WHEN DID YOU
FIRST LEARN OR COME TO BELIEVE
THAT THE STEELE DOSSIER WAS
FUNDED BY THE DEMOCRATIC
NATIONAL COMMITTEE AND TO THE
CLINTON CAMPAIGN?
HILLARY AND THE DNC,
DONNA BRAZILE CALLED AND
CONTROLLING THE MONEY IN THE
DNC, PAYING $12 MILLION FOR THE
GOVERNMENT LIES, PROPAGANDA TO
PROPAGANDIZE THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, INFLUENCE THE ELECTION,
AND OTHER QUESTION ASKING WHEN
DID YOU FIRST BECOME AWARE THAT
THE STEELE DOSSIER WAS USED TO
ORDER A FISA ORDER ON CARTER
PAGE.
WE KNOW FROM TWO REPUBLICAN
MEMOS THAT THE DOSSIER TO SPY ON
CARTER PAGE, TRUMP ASSOCIATES
OCTOBER 2016 BEFORE THE
ELECTION, IT WAS REMOVED THREE
TIMES AFTERWARDS.
AND YET PEOPLE LIKE JAMES COMEY,
ANDREW McCABE, SALLY YATES,
ROD ROSENSTEIN COMING WE CANNOT
CANNOT FORGET TO LISA PAGE AND
HER BOYFRIEND, AND DANA PENTAD.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT BUT KADE
TESTIFIED WITHOUT THE DOSSIER,
THE FISA WARRANT NEVER WOULD
HAVE BEEN APPROVED.
AND SPEAKING OF THE APPLICATION.
THE BULK OF THAT FISA WARRANT
APPLICATION RELIED ON THE
GARBAGE, THE DOSSIER HAD IN IT,
THE FUSION GPS AND THE FBI NEVER
VERIFIED.
THAT IS EVEN MORE TROUBLING,
BECAUSE JAMES COMEY SAID IT WAS
SALACIOUS AND I'M VERIFIED.
ANY ALSO BRIEFED
PRESIDENT-ELECT TRUMP ABOUT THE
FAKE NEWS DOSSIER, AND THAT WAS
IN JANUARY 2017, AND HE SAID THE
SAME THING TO DONALD TRUMP.
HE SAID IT WAS UNVERIFIED AND
SALACIOUS.
ONCE EARLIER IN OCTOBER, COMEY
HAD NO PROBLEM USING IT TO GET
THE FISA WARRANT TO SURVEY WILL
CARTER PAGE.
ON TO THE NEXT POINT, WAS
PRESIDENT OBAMA BRIEFED ON ANY
INFORMATION CONTAINED IN THE
DOSSIER PRIOR TO JANUARY 5TH,
2017?
NOW WE KNOW ABOUT JANUARY 5TH IN
THAT MEETING BECAUSE THE FORMER
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISOR, SUSAN
RICE IS THE ONE THAT SENT HER
EMAIL TO HERSELF ON
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S INAUGURATION
DAY.
AND ON HER WAY OUT OF THE
WHITE HOUSE, RICE DESCRIBES A
MEETING FROM JANUARY 5TH, 15
DAYS PRIOR WHEN SHE AND
JOE BIDEN, JAMES COMEY, THE
DEPUTY ATTORNEY WERE ALL IN THIS
MEETING.
SHE STRESSED, BARACK OBAMA
WANTED EVERYTHING WITH THE
RUSSIAN INVESTIGATION TO BE DONE
BY THE BOOK.
HE WANTED IT BY THE BOOK.
HE DID NOT INSTIGATE THIS
INVESTIGATION.
HE WANTED IT TO BUY THE BOOK.
SOUNDS LIKE A CYA, AND WHY WOULD
RICE IN THE EMAIL ON HER WAY OUT
OF THE WHITE HOUSE, SEEMS LIKE
SHE IS TRYING TO COVER HERSELF
AND PRESIDENT OBAMA.
THEY SAY THAT THE EMAIL WAS NOT
UNUSUAL AT ALL.
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT?
NOW ASKING THOSE OFFICIALS IF
THEY HAD CONTACT WITH THE MEDIA
ABOUT THE DOSSIER, AND WE
LEARNED THAT THE FORMER BRITISH
SPY, CHRISTOPHER STEELE WAS
BREACHING OUT MUCH LIKE
"THE NEW YORK TIMES,"
"THE WASHINGTON POST," YAHOO!
NEWS, FAKE NEWS CNN, ALL ABOUT
THE DOSSIER BEFORE THE ELECTION,
AND NUNES IS GIVING THESE
OFFICIALS UNTIL MARCH THE SECOND
TO REPLY.
WE DID REACH OUT TO FORMER
PRESIDENT OBAMA FOR THE COMMENT,
SHOCKINGLY THEY NEVER GOT BACK
TO US.
SO IN ADDITION TO FINDING OUT
WHAT OBAMA KNEW WHEN HE KNEW IT
WHEN IT COMES TO THE DOSSIER, WE
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE RUSSIAN
INTELLECTION
ELECTION INTERFERENCE.
THE MUELLER INDICTMENT SAYS THAT
IT STARTED IN 2014, DONALD TRUMP
WAS NOT RUNNING, AND WE NOW KNOW
DESPITE WARNINGS BACK IN 2014
FROM PEOPLE LIKE CONGRESSMAN
DEVIN NUNES, PRESIDENT OBAMA DID
NOTHING.
WE ARE CALLING IT A DERELICTION
OF DUTY, ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU
CONSIDER WHAT OBAMA SAID JUST A
COUPLE OF WEEKS BEFORE THE
ELECTION LECTURING DONALD TRUMP
TO STOP WHINING.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I HAVE NEVER SEEN IN MY
LIFETIME OR IN MODERN POLITICAL
HISTORY ANY PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATE TRYING TO DISCREDIT
THE ELECTIONS AND THE ELECTION
PROCESS BEFORE VOTES HAVE EVEN
TAKEN PLACE.
IT IS UNPRECEDENTED.
IT HAPPENS TO BE BASED ON NO
FACTS.
THERE IS NO SERIOUS PERSON OUT
SOMEHOW YOU COULD EVEN RIG
AMERICA'S ELECTIONS.
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE THAT THAT
HAS HAPPENED IN THE PAST OR THAT
THERE ARE INSTANCES WHERE THAT
WILL HAPPEN THIS TIME.
AND SO, I WOULD ADVISE MR. TRUMP
TO STOP WHINING AND TRY TO MAKE
HIS CASE.
>> Sean: HOW ABOUT YOU STOP
WHINING, NO SERIOUS PRESIDENT
WOULD'VE IGNORED THE WARNINGS IN
2014, THEY WOULD'VE KNOWN THAT
RUSSIA WAS A HOSTILE NATION WITH
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
REMEMBER, REMEMBER, TELL
VLADIMIR THAT MORE FLEXIBILITY
AFTER THE ELECTION.
IT IS TIME FOR PRESIDENT OBAMA,
YOU HAVE TO TELL THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE WHAT YOU KNEW AND WHEN
YOU KNEW IT ON THE DOSSIER AND
ESPECIALLY, WE WANT TO FIND OUT
WHAT THE FORMER PRESIDENT KNEW
AND WHEN DID YOU KNOW THAT
HILLARY CLINTON, THE DNC PAID
FOR THE RUSSIAN LIES, DID HE
KNOW THAT THE DOSSIER WAS USED
TO SPY ON A MEMBER OF THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN IN AN ELECTION YEAR?
AND WHY DID OBAMA NOT ACT?
IS IT BECAUSE HE THOUGHT THAT
HILLARY CLINTON WAS GOING TO WIN
HILLARY CLINTON WAS GOING TO WI
WIN.
THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN SLAMMING
OBAMA ON TWITTER,
PRESIDENT TRUMP THAT IS, FOR HIS
RESPONSE TO NOT TO RESPOND TO
RUSSIAN INTERFERENCE.
HERE IS PRESIDENT TRUMP'S RECENT
TWEET "I HAVE BEEN MUCH TOUGHER
ON RUSSIA THAN OBAMA, LOOK AT
ALL OF THE FACTS, TOTAL FAKE
NEWS."
AND SARAH SANDERS SCHOOLS THE
MEDIA TODAY ON HOW
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS BEEN MUCH
TOUGHER ON RUSSIA THAN OBAMA,
LIBERAL MEDIA, I KNOW THAT YOU
DO NOT DO ANY WORK, YOU MAY
WANT TO PAY CLOSE ATTENTION,
MAYBE LEARN SOMETHING.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> IF RUSSIA OR ANYBODY ELSE IS
TRYING TO INTERFERE WITH OUR
ELECTION, I THINK THAT IT IS A
HORRIBLE THING.
AND I WANT TO GET TO THE BOTTOM
OF IT AND MAKE SURE THAT IT WILL
NEVER, NEVER HAPPEN.
THE THING THAT I HAVE TO MENTION
IS THAT BARACK OBAMA WHEN HE WAS
PRESIDENT FOUND OUT ABOUT THIS,
HE WAS TOLD IN EARLY AUGUST BY
PRESUMABLY THE CIA THAT RUSSIA
WAS TRYING TO GET INVOLVED OR
MEDDLING, PRETTY STRONGLY WITH
THE ELECTION, HE DID NOTHING
ABOUT IT.
THE REASON IS THAT HE THOUGHT
HILLARY WAS GOING TO WIN.
>> WE CANNOT LET ANYBODY PLAY
AROUND WITH HER VOTERS AND OUR
VOTER SYSTEM, BUT I HAVE TO TELL
YOU THIS --
[APPLAUSE]
>> Tucker: WE WILL HAVE MORE
EXAMPLES ABOUT HOW OBAMA FAILEDO
EXAMPLES ABOUT HOW OBAMA FAILEDE
EXAMPLES ABOUT HOW OBAMA FAILEDR
AND OVER AGAIN, THIS IS LATER IN
AND OVER AGAIN, THIS IS LATER IT
AND OVER AGAIN, THIS IS LATER IE
AND OVER AGAIN, THIS IS LATER IS
AND OVER AGAIN, THIS IS LATER IO
AND OVER AGAIN, THIS IS LATER I,
AND OVER AGAIN, THIS IS LATER IT
AND OVER AGAIN, THIS IS LATER II
AND OVER AGAIN, THIS IS LATER IS
INCLUDES URANIUM ONE AND
ALLOWING VLADIMIR PUTIN TO GET
CONTROL OF 20% OF OUR URANIUM
WHEN IT IS IN SHORT SUPPLY.
WHY WOULD ANY ADMINISTRATION LED
A HOSTILE FOREIGN ACTOR EVER DO
THAT TO THIS COUNTRY?
WE ALSO HAVE BEEN TELLING YOU
ABOUT HOW IT ALL STARTED IN
2009, YOU HAVE A VLADIMIR PUTIN
LEAD RUSSIAN OPERATIVE RIGHT
HERE IN AMERICAN SOIL, THEY OPEA
HERE IN AMERICAN SOIL, THEY OPEE
AND WANT A FOOTHOLD IN THE
URANIUM MARKET, REMEMBER?
WE HAVE BEEN TELLING YOU ABOUT
DOUGLAS CAMPBELL, HE WAS THERE
THE ENTIRE TIME.
DOCUMENTING AND UNCOVERING
EVERYTHING, BRIBERY, EXTORTION,
MONEY KICKBACKS, MONEY
LAUNDERING.
AND THEY DID NOTHING, HOW IS
THAT POSSIBLE?
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL ROBERT
MOHLER ANNOUNCES A NEW PLEA DEAL
WITH THE TIDE TO PALM TO PAUL
MANAFORT AND RICK GATES.
NO COLLUSION.
AND INCLUDING THE LEGAL
DOCUMENTS IN SOME INTERESTING
INFORMATION.
AND THE LAWYER DELETED -- THAT
SOUNDS FAMILIAR AND DID NOT HAND
OVER EMAILS THAT HAD BEEN
REQUESTED BY THE SPECIAL COUNSEL
REQUESTED BY THE SPECIAL COUNSE
COUNSEL.
IS ROBERT MOELLER SETTING A
LEGAL STANDARD CUSTOMER CASEY
SETTING A PRECEDENT?
DO WE NOW GO BACK AND GET
HILLARY CLINTON, SHE DELETED,
ACID WATCHED, AND BEAT IT WITH A
HAMMER.
HE THINKS WHAT THIS LAWYER DID
WAS WRONG AND ILLEGAL AND SHOULD
TAKE A COLD HARD LOOK AT THE
33,000 AND EMAILS THAT WERE
SUBPOENAED THAT SHE ERASED AND
THEN ACID WASHED, BLEACH PIT AND
HAD IT BEAT UP WITH A HAMMER.
THAT IS A GOOD START.
AND HER TEAM FBI CELL PHONES, WE
HAVE TO GIVE THEM CREDIT.
THEY DID NOT HAVE ANY SIM CARDS
IN THEM, WHICH BASICALLY
RENDERED THEM USELESS.
SO IF MUELLER CARES A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE EQUAL APPLICATION
UNDER THE LAW, HE WOULD BE
INVESTIGATING HILLARY CLINTON
FOR DESTROYING EVIDENCE SOMATIC
EVIDENCE IN AN FBI
INVESTIGATION.
THAT WOULD BE JUST THE START OF
THE LEGAL TROUBLES.
WE TOLD YOU LAST NIGHT ABOUT AN
ARTICLE WRITTEN BY A LAWYER,
ROBERT BARNES FOR THE WEBSITE
"LAW AND CRIME."
HERE'S THE HEADLINE, DOES
MUELLER'S INDICTMENT MEAN
LINTON'S CAMPAIGN AND BEING
INDICTED HERSELF OR CHRISTOPHER
STEELE?
BECAUSE BARNES IS POINTING OUT
THAT SINCE ROBERT MUELLER
INDICTED RUSSIAN PROBES FOR
FAILING TO REGISTER AS FOREIGN
AGENTS AND NOT REPORTING THEIR
ACTIVITIES TO THE FTC, IT IS IN
THE OVERALL TEXT IF YOU READ IT,
WILL THAT BE A LEGAL STANDARD
FOR THEM TO GO AFTER CHRISTOPHER
STEELE, FUSION GPS, THE LAW FIRM
STEELE, FUSION GPS, THE LAW FIR
FIRM?
DNC, AND HILLARY CLINTON
HERSELF?
HERE'S THE REASON WHY,
CHRISTOPHER STEELE IS A FOREIGN
CITIZEN'S CITIZEN.
WE HAVE NOT SEEN THAT HE NEVER
REGISTERED AS A -- SO IF WE ARE
GOING TO GO OFF OF THE PRECEDENT
SET BY THE RUSSIAN INDICTMENT,
ALL OF THE CONDITIONS ARE THERE
IN THIS CASE, ROBERT MUELLER
SHOULD BE INVESTIGATING STEEL,
LINTON, FUSION GPS,
HILLARY CLINTON.
ISN'T IT ABOUT FAIRNESS AND
EQUAL APPLICATION OF THE LAW?
IF MUELLER IS GOING AFTER
RUSSIAN TROLLS, MAYBE HE WILL BE
OKAY WITH PROSECUTING
CHRISTOPHER STEELE AND THE
PEOPLE PAYING HIM TO CREATE A PO
PEOPLE PAYING HIM TO CREATE A PY
DOSSIER FULL OF RUSSIAN LIES AS
THEY TRY TO USE TO LIE TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
RUSH LIMBAUGH HAD AN AMAZING
POINT ON HIS RADIO SHOW ABOUT
WHY MUELLER ONLY INDICTED THE
RUSSIANS FOR CERTAIN REASONS
PRETTY NAILS IT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE THINGS THAT THE RUSSIANS
WERE CHARGED WITH IN THE
INDICTMENT OR WIRE FRAUD,
DEFRAUDING THE UNITED STATES,
MAIL FRAUD.
THESE CHARGES THAT THE RUSSIANS
WERE HIT WITH IN THIS INDICTMENT
HAVE NOTHING TO DO WITH THE
AVOWED PURPOSE OF THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL INVESTIGATION.
LITERALLY NOTHING.
AND IF THESE RUSSIANS WERE
CHARGED THE WAY THAT EVERYBODY
THOUGHT CHARGES WERE GOING TO
HAPPEN, THEN THEY COULD NOT
CHARGE HILLARY AND THEY COULD
CHARGE CHRISTOPHER STEELE AND
FUSION GPS.
BUT THEY CAN'T BE CHARGED JUST
BECAUSE THE RUSSIANS HAVE BEEN,
BECAUSE THE CHARGES ARE
DIFFERENT.
>> Sean: THAT'S WHY THEY DID
NOT GO AFTER THE FTC ISSUES, WHY
THEY DID NOT GO AFTER THE BARK
ISSUE.
WATCH RUSSIAN AND SAY LET NECK
IS SAYING HERE IS BRILLIANT.
THAT THEY MAY HAVE BEEN
SHIELDING HILLARY CLINTON BY THE
RUSSIAN TROLLS, BECAUSE ALL OF
THAT COULD HAVE BEEN PROVIDED TO
FUSION GPS, HILLARY CLINTON, THE
CAMPAIGN, PERKINS COOLEY, AND
THE REST OF THEM.
BRILLIANT POINT, SO MUELLER
AGAIN, HILLARY CLINTON, HOW DOES
SHE GET EVERYBODY TO PROTECT
HER?
FINALLY TONIGHT WE HAVE MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT THE PARTISAN
ATTACK DOG, LOOK AT THE
"L.A. TIMES" GETTING ON BOARD,
FINALLY DOING SOME REPORTING IN
THE MEDIA.
MUELLER DEPUTY ANDREW WEISSMANN
HAS A REPUTATION FOR THE TACTIC
AND SOMETIMES GOING TOO FAR.
THEN THE "L.A. TIMES" DETAILS
HOW ANDREW WEISSMANN HAS VERY
CLOSE TIES TO THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL ROBERT MUELLER SERVING
AS HIS FBI GENERAL COUNSEL FOR
TWO YEARS.
MAYBE THIS WILL EXPLAIN WHY
MUELLER DECIDED TO TAP ANDREW
WEISSMANN AS HIS TOP PROSECUTOR
EVEN THOUGH HE HAS THE MOST
ATROCIOUS RECORD OF ANY LAWYER
I'VE EVER SEEN IN MY LIFE.
WE TOLD YOU HOW HE IS BIASED, A
POLITICAL PARTISAN HACK, DONATED
THOUSANDS HAD THE INCLUDING
OBAMA AND DESPITE THE POLITICAL
BIAS, WHAT ABOUT HIS TRACK
RECORD AS A PROSECUTOR?
SARA CARTER BROKE THE STORY
ABOUT HOW A 1997 CASE, ANDREW
WEISSMANN WAS REPRIMANDED BY A
JUDGE FOR WITHHOLDING EVIDENCE.
NOT THE FIRST TIME.
AND IN THE END HE GOT TO BAILED
OUT BY HIS POWERFUL FRIEND, HIS
NAME WAS RETROACTIVELY REMOVED
FROM THE COMPLAINT.
THAT IS JUST THE TIP OF THE
ICEBERG WHEN IT COMES TO ANDREW
WEISSMANN.
AS PART OF THE SCANDAL, REMEMBER
HIS AGGRESSIVE TACTICS?
ANDERSEN ACCOUNTING GOES OUT OF
BUSINESS.
IT COST TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
JOBS, PEOPLE LOST THEIR JOBS,
ANDREW WEISSMANN SECURED A
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE
CONVICTION AGAINST ANDERSON, THA
CONVICTION AGAINST ANDERSON, THT
CONVICTION AGAINST ANDERSON, THW
CONVICTION AGAINST ANDERSON, THS
OVERTURNED BY THE SUPREME COURT
COMING AN ENORMOUS 9-0.
HE PUT FOUR EXECUTIVES IN JAIL
FOR A YEAR.
ALSO OVERTURNED BY THE FIFTH
CIRCUIT COURT OF APPEALS.
IN THE "L.A. TIMES" IS REPORTING
AS PART OF THE ENRON
PROSECUTION, ANDREW WEISSMANN
NAMED 114 PEOPLE AS
UNINDICTED COCONSPIRATORS.
WHY IS THAT IMPORTANT?
BECAUSE DEFENSE LAWYERS ARGUED
THAT BY THREATENING THESE 114
PEOPLE PROSECUTED            PRO
PEOPLE PROSECUTED            PRE
PEOPLE PROSECUTED            PRU
PEOPLE PROSECUTED            PRI
PEOPLE PROSECUTED            PRN
PEOPLE PROSECUTED            PR,
PEOPLE PROSECUTED            PRH
PEOPLE PROSECUTED            PRE
PEOPLE PROSECUTED            PRW
PEOPLE PROSECUTED            PRS
PEOPLE PROSECUTED            PRA
PEOPLE PROSECUTED            PRL
PEOPLE PROSECUTED            PRE
TO BLOCK TESTIMONY THAT COULD
HAVE HELPED THE CLIENTS.
SO ANDREW WEISSMANN ONCE AGAIN H
SO ANDREW WEISSMANN ONCE AGAIN L
SO ANDREW WEISSMANN ONCE AGAIN I
SO ANDREW WEISSMANN ONCE AGAIN G
EVIDENCE.
IT'S HARD TO FATHOM HOW ANYBODY
IS CORRECTING LET NECK
CORRUPTING AS WISEMAN COULD BE
CONSIDERED TO BE A PART OF THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL TEAM?
YES SO MANY RED FLAGS, BUT YET
MUELLER TOOK HIM ON.
HE IS HIS PIT BULL AND THAT'S MY
TWO RISE JUDGMENT ABOUT HIS